and then we gonna have a good time a
dozen hands up to the sky we gonna chose
did you know get it babe we got a spark
a little rise let away
I'm counting down and do a starter and
again we come to play yeah we play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast new year new season
new set new set vibe we are so excited I
cannot believe that like actually a lot
of toasters like figured out even though
you know me I'm not the queen of
subtlety but like no social media I was
really trying not to be like Thursday no
you weren't even being subtle like you
didn't say anything yet they sussed it
out they know everything we're so
excited very sad it's such a gloomy day
here in New York because part of the
reason Jackie and I moved from our
previous studio was many reasons but one
we're in New York show we wanted it to
feel like New York we have this amazing
new studio with all these windows and
it's like the Sun is nowhere to be found
but that's just us that's just that a
psyche who could ask for Sun on a day
like today but it's really the Monday
it's Monday ever but the toast is back
so it's the best day ever and Thea's
here it's the best day ever our new set
is going to continue to evolve so please
stay with us we have tons of very toasty
new furniture coming new cameras new
lights but we were just excited to get
started this has been a very long
process and a very expensive process
being an entreprenuer is you know really
times are tough for the Entrepreneurship
world but I have so much respect from
our cube and after what we went through
in putting this set together but we did
it I feel very proud just crazy to like
I own this microphone Multan we own this
mic yeah I don't know in the business
owns this night this microphone is the
tax write-off yeah totally it's just
it's all very exciting we were gone for
so long so much happened but we've been
like working on this for so long that it
doesn't feel like we haven't been here
you don't even think the toast hasn't
been on and so on like really I've been
at this office every day yeah and we
couldn't say anything and it's just been
so crazy and we're so excited to be here
and what's very exciting is that we did
vlog the entire process so if you are a
patreon member you will get that vlog
the making of a studio up until this
morning we were filming we were just
having so much stuff so any technical
difficulties everything seems to go be
going so much just from your mouth
to God's ears but you know if we drop
off at any point like you can find us in
the podcast or later today also we have
brand new podcast mics or our audio
should be more snatched than ever if
you're listening to this as a podcast hi
how are you I hope you're enjoying these
levels level up yes this is level up
season yeah um you know what people are
doing for 2020 which I'm really enjoying
people are choosing like words to live
their year by oh I did see that I also
saw that Shane and Emily from houses of
Orange County are finding words for
their marriage oh well I saw it on Tonya
rods story and I'm course so excited to
hear what her 20/20 word whatever and
she gave me a sneak peak I hope that she
announced it already but it's 20/20 so
she did and it was level up which is
what we're doing here we're so leveling
up I'm so excited bark how it is to come
I'm so excited for all of our tables and
our lights and we got our very toasty
carpet and I'm so excited for one of the
best new pieces of furniture that we're
gonna get which is the Sun one day and
you'll be able to see these beautiful
cityscape yes we have a northeastern
view of Manhattan very very beautiful I
think you can also see a glimpse of Long
Island City because you know we're a
borough friendly borough equal show yes
we're very borough inclusive do you
remember like learning about their
burrows in school yeah and that like new
Manhattan is in all of New York City
right so there's Manhattan Staten Island
the Bronx Brooklyn Queens wow I can't
believe I remembered all five good time
good times good times good times to be a
New Yorker so much happened for us
personally since the show was on and I'm
sure everyone saw but we are so like
over the moon like can't even breathe
excited that our sister Olivia is
pregnant it's just been such a simcha
for us we are so happy like the first
bit like look how we are for Theo like
when it's a real human like I mean that
eventually can talk back to us that's
what I always say to Ben I'm like I love
the O so much don't get me wrong but
like the fact that he will never like
evolve like the most he'll really ever
evolve is like learning to [ __ ] you know
in my bedroom is you on the concrete
like that's the evolution of the dog and
I'm like he's never really gonna be able
to tell me how much he loves me
right wears like a child grows and their
emotions and they're able to tell you
how much they love you right and then
eventually they'll tell you how much
they hate you exciting very exciting
what else happened on the break so much
so much happened oh we have to talk
about the fight that I got into on
Saturday night
I wasn't being clicked baby on my
Instagram I just really felt like it was
a story pertinent for the toast
and it was so shocking it was so
shocking also we kept our vacations a
little bit on patreon I just want to say
it was like the most incredible vacation
and just like I've been home for a week
now and it's just been a wonderful
vacation but it makes me want to like
work hard so that I can vacation more
competitors I find vacations to be and
it's like such a lame word I apologize
for using a conjunction junction what's
your function on this show really no
there weren't for it I just like ruined
this new show I'm so sorry but I already
called it a Monday I feel like there's
nothing more relaxing than staying at
home for vacation like and don't get me
wrong a beach vacation is so nice but
there's a lot of treacherous that's
involved in going on a beach vacation I
mean not only do you have to get on a
plane all the traveling and you hope you
end up in a new land that you also have
to be like sweaty into bathing suit like
in front of strangers like there's a lot
of elements that are relaxing about a
beach vacation but there's also things
that aren't there's absolutely nothing
not relaxing about staying home and
these lap this last weekend half that
I've been home while we've been working
on the studio like every day just like
waking up in my bed like there's
something even though we were
technically working being home without
having any real responsibilities like
that that's why I used to love so much
about college at the five-week winter
break that was nuts like that was some
of the greatest times of my life for
sure but that's like the most weight
I've ever gained in a five-week period
in my life oh yeah I am just on this
like journey of like non-stop eating and
I think that I'll look back on this year
of my life and feel like January was the
most important month I just have like so
many things happening and I'll be like
Claudia you should have stopped eating
but you know what I'm just like too busy
to stuff you need to fuel all of the
things you have happening yeah that
can't be hungry at a time like that I
don't even care like I just I can't care
I have my snatch Fendi jacket that I
overpaid for and I'm just like getting
my money's worth every time I wear it
over paid for it but like you're so
thankful that you did I'm so thankful
that I got this jacket like it is such
an exorbitant thing but like I truly
don't care I wear it so much I work
three times this week and I just I
warrant like out and Malibu once like I
just think this jacket is so versatile
I'm like I can wear it on the slopes of
Aspen or the beaches of Malibu love to
see it and it would be pertinent in both
situations totally also I just say like
how much I miss cutting you off like
it's just it's so exciting it's fine
also before the break I was
playing a lot how like my life is not
balanced we're like either I'm working
so hard or I'm being a sloth and I
actually came up with the solution for
the imbalance in my life and that has
been books because now I read instead of
watching TV and how can you feel like an
unproductive like piece of [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] if you're reading books
yeah it's amazing so now I read like
books like their hallmark movies and I
really feel like I've found that's what
you call balance well we spoke about
this on the patreon so I won't go into
it too much but I do read one book over
the break and by the way it was really
thick book it was like 500 pages on the
Howard Stern book really really good
she's been their hands in September and
by the way ever since I read The Howard
Stern book I have now had two dreams
about Howard Stern I'm a judge about one
of them and then the other one I was
doing a big show in the Bahamas and
Howard Stern showed up Wow like the
production wasn't working there was
nobody around the audio like I said it
was a nightmare and I kept waking up
from the dream being like yeah it's not
real going back to sleep and going back
into the dream I couldn't get out of the
dream it was crazy I had to wake up
fully just to get out of it
interesting I believe that's what people
call a nightmare except Howard Stern was
there that's true but it really gets a
chat with him because he was like so
disappointed in me you know so upsetting
I'm sorry
for you know that I am is there anything
else let's go fight your fight oh my god
okay so Saturday night we went out for
Margo illumines birthday we had dinner
and catch it's been a minute since we've
been to catch and it was so funny
because we were saying we were waiting
for our table and I literally turned to
everyone I'm like you know it's such a
shame that this restaurant is like so
trashy because the food is so good but
in recent years it has really become
like really just not elevated anymore
like yes it's just that landing it's not
land yeah like there's just girls and
hooker dresses everywhere at their
titties out but we still go because the
food is so good and it's honestly the
vibe it's right and the locations good
it was just funny because I had
literally just said yeah so we were not
to make the fight about it right we were
seated at a table and it was a real it
was so busy at catch and so we were
seedy kind of close to the table next to
us and I was bearing the brunt of that
because I was back to back with the girl
at the table behind us and it was like
uncomfortable
throughout them like in the beginning
like when she would flip her hair I
would feel it you know how that happens
sometimes had it like a busy poppy and
restaurant but it's like not a big deal
you were both living with it like I'm
definitely knowing for you you didn't
really say anything I'm sure it was
annoying for her yeah I'm sure she felt
me like when I moved but it's like
that's what happens when you go to a
busy restaurant in New York City like
welcome to New York okay anyways at one
point she gets up to go to the bathroom
and I was like oh nice like I can
breathe for a second and
I've been trying to move to the left or
to the right trying to like figure it
out but whatever it's just called like
having a meal at a busy restaurant like
not a big deal how'd it go anyways the
girls come back from the bathroom this
girl sits in the chair and shoves all
the way into me and they turn around
it's a different girl that was sitting
there we were she should've Jack his
chair so close to the table Jack his
titties were like being served she she
was literally choking yes literally like
up against the table and they turn
around like excuse me and she said oh
I'm like excuse me you're pressing up
against me that can you please move and
she's like I don't know and I stepped in
I was like
sis you were literally choking my sister
move like yeah it wasn't it was
pertinent I loved you I just was turned
around like please [ __ ] move but I'm
still up here up against the table like
please man she's like what are you
talking about I'm like listen like don't
be a beast she was a waste it I was like
you could move to the left I can move to
the right just like please move I'm
choking up against the table and she was
just like pretending be stupid
then her friend comes over and I was a
friend who was sitting in the chair
originally who obviously told her friend
to take her seat and shove into me cuz
they were like talking in the bathroom
about me like so interesting for their
lives she comes over and she goes you've
been at this restaurant for 12 minutes
we've been here for three hours I was
like okay so leave like that was the
best part of the fight I was like you're
done with your meal like go up to the
club it's so much fun why you guys
sitting here pushing into me they were
trying to say like we deserve to push
you because we've been here for three
hours it's like okay so you've eaten
already we had to wait 45 minutes for a
table because of people like you who've
already paid the check and now we're
just taking up the table so it was just
getting so heated they were making such
dumb arguments they were wasted they
were such trash like this girl was
literally her nipples were out like it
was it was a level of trash Lamia I've
never experienced I was just watching I
really disappointed no but it was so
funny like the way our table reacted
versus theirs because our table we were
all like we don't get into fights so we
were all just like sitting around
snickering well you guys were and I was
just really trying to tell her like
still move I can still press evidence of
sitting just like laughing at how crazy
this was and one by one they're all
getting they're all getting up like
throwing hands and I want to go outside
I just like two minutes and then like
the manager and security came over and
like this girl's like coming up over
security video do you wanna go outside
I'm like no I don't like it's raining
yeah we just got our appetizers we're
just like really looking for a fight
with like the wrong group of people like
we are just not the type of girls to
throw down in the middle of a crowded
restaurant no and I just like I kept
calling this girl a beast because I
think it's the most pertinent and so on
I just higher temperatures of the camera
for bringing it into my vernacular
because it insults someone like a
physical and mental level and I was
saying like your behavior is beastly
your physicality yeah and also you are
beasts yeah and then she was looking at
me I had an extra hair clip and she was
like it's extra headband literally says
extra beast and I was like your face
says extra beat it was moved
conversation like the and then so then
eventually security comes after they're
asking us to go out after the other
table was like trying to take it to the
parking lot and they are kicked out
because they had already paid the check
and they were sitting there for three
hours and probably hadn't even gotten
our appetizers yeah they were all kicked
out and then people were coming over and
they're like oh my god we've been
watching that table they've been
drinking for three hours these girls
were trashed so what was so funny was
that like catches the toe CS restaurant
like I never go there and judge C 1000
toasters and there was like ten tables
around us of toasters like they were so
nice I mean just happened to be seated
not only to the people who were in
toasters but they were insane like I've
never seen such trash in my life
honestly felt like an episode of Bad
Girls Club it really really didn't and
didn't have to get to that level okay
like you shoved into me but I turned
around and just asked you to move like
you could have moved it didn't have to
go to the tenant parking they started it
in a very physical way and then they all
just like got up and we're throwing
hands and like I just I honestly thought
that was only the type of stuff that
like I see on fire I'm sure like I
didn't think that happened in real life
it was it was so absurd and I just have
to give so much credit to Jackie like I
am a beast but I think when I am like
faced with confrontation I totally run
away you were so standing up for
yourself like I couldn't believe like
how much you were taking it head on when
I was like I literally would have cried
and ran away no I couldn't believe it
either but it was just like I don't know
what I feel like I haven't been out in
so long like I'm having a couple drinks
with my friends I deserve to sit just as
much as you do obviously more because
they already had three hours right right
and like they look like they're out
every single night like I'm not so you
know what like I'm gonna enjoy myself
I'm gonna take up my seat and you're
gonna [ __ ] move no it was you guys it
was so crazy these girls just came back
from the bathroom like looking for a
fight no and I think the key point is
that she had her friend take her seat so
that she would shove into me like they
sent in the linebacker yeah no that's
like we would have what we would have
done like if Olivia was there right ID
Olivia push Olivia wasn't there
obviously and I literally facetimed her
because it was such an Olivia
would have really like that's what
Olivia was me for she protects us she's
like a mama bear and I just know like if
she would have been there like it would
have turned out so differently and I
called her mic Olivia you would have
been so proud of Jackie she completely
stood up for herself like literally none
of us even chimed in no and like we were
all just like none of us no one even
stood up meanwhile their whole table was
up like yeah no fist-pumping it was
insane it was insane and then when we
left the restaurant we were being so
dramatic we like thought they were
waiting outside for us because they were
not done no and they were just so drunk
and like it's like a dog with a bone and
you just like if you want to get into a
fight that's why they get into many
fights I'm far away I'm a sure it's like
all the drinking everything's heightened
do you think you're so right and it's
like I'm sorry when you're shoving
people into tables you're just not right
you ain't right says you ain't right but
just a great memory for the grandpa yeah
totally it just I had so much adrenaline
after that I actually needed to drink
more - just like quell my nerves oh and
if you think we spoke about anything
else for the rest of the night
raagh we couldn't stop like it I just
never experienced like trash like that
and I was just so excited no it was so
crazy and now I think we need to get
into more fight I think it's gonna be my
thing of 2020 like start more bar fights
so you know what's so crazy anytime you
get into an altercation or the one time
like you always think like oh I should
have said this I should have said that
and like it was the first time in my
life where I had absolutely no regrets
that's a good feeling
I had regrets I would think of your
comeback later I'm like no totally
I felt like Jeremiah from Florida I'm
sure you know he's like a big guy and
then like when there's a fight he's
always running away and that's I got
people's beef with him in the house
that's me like I have a big talk and
then like I let her just time watch and
I was freaking out like I could just
couldn't believe what was happening
yeah sorry if I let you down no no one
let me down I tried I totally had it
covered cuz I was completely in the
right like you don't coach having people
just because we're back-to-back like I
know it's uncomfortable for you it's
uncomfortable for me it's just a fact of
life right it's just what you get when
you go to a popin restaurant right
that's located in thought Lamia right
maybe go somewhere less poppin if you
can't handle it early-bird special if
you can't handle the pop okay Adam they
consciously going back to catch tonight
but the new catch steak have you been
now people are was asking for restaurant
recommendations I have heard that it's
amazing so I'm going tonight and I will
report back tomorrow very exciting I
look forward to hearing it I think it's
like celeb land eeeh totally well
there's so much I mean need to talk
about so much has happened since we've
been gone the Golden Globes were on last
night yes that will be part of the past
five and I
we'll just be going in and out of every
different thing that we experience yes
you know it's the last two weeks I am
just so happy to be here th EO is being
such a good boy I don't want to like
wake him up but he's just the light of
my life and I'm so glad that you know
it's a new year but absolutely nothing
has changed in my relationship with my
son and I feel really proud I'm so proud
for you and actually one thing has
changed is that he now knows that he's
gonna be a cousin and you can really see
like the cousin vibes coming out do you
think that's actually gonna be like hard
for him like cuz he's not a real person
like dogs just want attention I don't
think it will be hard for him I think
he's gonna be so excited to have someone
his own size you know yeah that he can
see eye-to-eye with I used to think like
he used to be such a [ __ ] I couldn't
used to be so judgmental of people who
would like let dogs near their newborns
like I would see pictures on Pinterest
of like huge golden retrievers like
laying with newborn babies and I'm like
that is such irresponsible parenting
like I used to tell Ben I'm like when we
have a child like the first year we're
gonna have to give Theo to Jackie or
something like and literally what an
idiot I was you know yeah that is so
wrong Theo literally would never hurt a
fly no he wouldn't certainly not a betta
Oh also but we didn't speak about which
I just want to mention really quickly is
I'm like being tick tock stars right we
had just been getting into take talk
before the break but I literally spent
the entire break on tick-tock like I
can't stop swiping like renegade
renegade who like I follow me girls no
jobs follow Jackie at Jackie O like we
are just consistently bumming out
amazing content here on tick-tock and I
just I'm obsessed to Charlie like I'm so
involved with like the tick-tock drama I
like there there's a tick-tock Facebook
group to toast it's so good thanks so
good they're like learn about all the
trends you know same um it's just it
really is a premium platform and I just
I love it for the children I can't say
that enough
and I also not only do I love the
children being creative like dancing in
the rooms opposed as opposed to like
being on Instagram
taking selfies editing them feeling bad
about themselves yeah but also like I
think all this dancing could solve
America's obesity epidemic I have so
many thoughts about tik-tok and its
benefits on our youth and I also feel
like I see some and I don't follow a lot
of people I just go to the main 4u page
and just see people from like all
different walks of life and it's like
these kids I could be doing so much
worse things like when I was a kid I was
like drunk in a field in the middle of
the night you know what I mean like
these kids could be doing so much worse
and I feel like tic TOCs really like
keeping them out of trouble weirdly and
like making them like fuel their energy
like more creative like funny I just
think it's such a great pop I think it's
such a great platform like I I stand I
stand yeah okay so we're gonna jump in
is that correct are you think it's time
do I think it's time I mean it's been so
long and it's hard to know and actually
it's been 17 minutes I do think it's
time I'm not wearing a watch so you know
it's hard to know I'm sorry if I'm wrong
but I do think that it's time okay
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast feels good to say
that again and yeah by the way I know I
said it was time and I don't want to
like take a step back on what I said
because I'm a woman of my word most of
the time um but I would be remiss like I
would be to have a seated I think I
would even be heartbroken if I didn't
let you guys know that today's episode
sponsor is so premium it's MTV's siesta
key it is back to heat up the winter on
Tuesday January 7th at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time Pacific the bachelorettes Robbie
Hayes is joining the cast for the
hottest season yet we had them on the
show a few weeks ago and Jackie and I
had the privilege of getting a sneak
peek at the first episode and I know
this is an ad but it's so good guys it's
so good if you've never watched an
episode of siesta key this is the one to
watch like I think TV viewers all over
the world are gonna be shocked and we
also do to Jonah Hill last night puts
the STK in at Instagram sorry no yes
Wow I know he's in a man who knows
premium content just as hurriedly siesta
key is back with more drama than ever
before welcoming the bachelorettes
Robbie Hayes to the crew dive into the
new season on Tuesday January 7th at 8
p.m. Eastern Time Pacific on MTV the
original gang is back with the
dissolution of siesta keys at couple
Alex and Juliet mmm debatable affair and
a couple has left the friends circle
divided new cast members invade the
scene bringing conflict heartbreak and
deception into the mix now the newly
minted crew must learn that taking risks
with love and friendship comes with a
cost
leaving lovers burned and friendships
irreversibly damaged I just like I'm not
trying to be a clique baby but you're
gonna see something in this first
episode that's gonna absolutely blow
your mind it's just you didn't think
like Madison would be the hero of the
season but she is you have to tune in to
the new season of siesta key January 7th
at 8 p.m. eastern Pacific such a good
show can recommend enough can't
recommend it enough I can't wait to
recap it and I also heard word on the
street is that the snatcher is gonna be
doing siesta key recaps now
well she should because it'll be you
know one small step in our big plan to
get her like mysteriously dating Jared
right and also because everyone on
Siesta Key is the snatcher it's only
appropriate that she would be talking
about them yes Japan sure comes back
tonight which means the snatcher comes
back in full force tomorrow like talking
about all things snitch and snatch and
I'm really excited about it I'm gonna
watch
I'm gonna watch - I actually really like
Peter I think he was a great choice I
didn't agree but I'll so watch okay well
I like to watch for the women I think
the women are interesting you know no
Peter Peter saw it he's just fake Nick
vile to me and make sure all he's ever
gonna be make sure you're subscribed so
much Nick vital to talk about make sure
to subscribe to the snatch our Apple
Spotify iTunes all the places I look
forward to hearing the snitches thoughts
video ok let's get into it because
there's a story that's the Golden Globes
yes what a show what a show
thanks to Ricky Gervais otherwise it
would have been another steaming hot
pile of [ __ ] yes but I mean Ricky
Gervais was impeccable but I do think
that it was better than ever because of
forget your face but also because I
think there were a record number of a
listers in one room like every year
people go because they're nominated but
maybe it was just this year's slate of
content but like every famous person was
there like I just thought it was even
Ryan Seacrest was saying on the red
carpet like there were so many
celebrities especially at the end they
gave Brad Pitt like one minute like no I
know I can't believe Brad Pitt went on a
red carpet like I was so shocked I was
so happy to hear from Brad Pitt
multiple times hot so hot daddy so much
to this guy hair okay we have the
complete list of winners which we'll get
to but nightly care um it's interesting
yeah but that's like really not why I
watched I watched for the fashion
obviously I watched for Ricky's your
base and I watched for just like the
inter communication of celebrity I
watched for Ricky Gervais and he hit it
out of the park like so what's the
opposite of tone-deaf I'm to touch hitch
perfect in touch like the magazine I
just finally got it was pitch perfect
even through and edit Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself joke and like he
just I really feel like something out
how summed up how so many people feel
about Hollywood and the fact that people
in Hollywood were laughing about it's
like oh we can all get along but he
really wasn't performing for the people
in the room he was performing it for the
people at home which I really appreciate
it's very hard to be a celebrity and
this is what Joan Rivers said in her
documentary which really struck me she's
like you can't get a seat at the table
if your job is to make fun at the table
so it's really hard to be a celebrity
and accepted by Hollywood when you as a
comedian or a host or just a commentator
your job is so dependent on making fun
of these people and it's really hard to
like be in the room but also make fun of
the room and I'm sure it was
uncomfortable at points but I thought he
was stellar stellar and I think also a
lot of the acceptance speeches were
better because it was under this guise
of like don't be so self congratulatory
like don't be so preachy your agent it
is what it is ya know don't be so
preachy and like I feel like a lot of
people whether or not you agree with
some of the political statements made an
award shows it just feels so silly
coming from a group of people who are so
hypocritical and you said it so
perfectly like if Isis made a streaming
service like you guys could be calling
your agents I can it's so true so guess
some of the sentiments are beautiful but
it's like to be honest hearing it from
you makes me disagree with you like even
if I agree with you Michele Williams
it's a woman's right to choose I agree
but like you just stop please just don't
like it's it's not what they're saying
it's just where it's coming from it's so
right Lily and it's so toned and I think
what keen Phoenix was actually getting
somewhere by the end of his speech um
but he got played off when he was saying
like you guys cannot talk about like
climate change but then you're taking
your private jets to Palm Springs I
thought he was gonna pledge an amount of
money at that moment and I was
envisioning him like taking bids like
who's gonna I'm gonna do a hundred
thousand anyone gonna match me I mean
maybe he was going to but he just
couldn't land the plane I couldn't land
the private plane in Palm Springs I
don't know him but I feel like he's
changed for the better
no I feel like I know him and I feel
like this time it's gonna be different
ya know I mean and I'm sure they say
that every time working like goes
through something I really like him I
love him and it's so funny because when
I got back from our GNO at like 3:00 in
the morning I was watching TV and since
Friends is no longer on Netflix which
we'll talk about I have nothing to watch
before bed and walk the line was on E
and I was literally just like sitting
there like with tears - Micah's movie so
good and Ben was like I've never seen it
I'm like never seen walk the line animal
like and then I just had this
appreciation in culture it's fine then I
have this appreciation in my heart for
walking Phoenix that just translate it
into the Golden Globes totally and then
we only talk with Reese Witherspoon was
beautiful so beautiful um okay we could
talk about some of the winners but I
wanted
here who your best dressed were I came
to top three for me so just feel free to
rattle him off my top three one of the
people on my top three is so rad I'm cuz
like she wasn't really there
but Kristin Cavallari on e did you see
what she wore I didn't she looked
amazing and she is the snatch allure she
is very but like I think she looked
great for Kristin Cavallari but that's a
safe choice on your part
I feel so on my yes on like she looks
great like there's yeah because
everybody looked terrible I'm not really
like scraping the bottom of the barrel
to think of three people who looked good
I started to once I was thinking about
it more I had I had I had trouble
whittling it down to three but my number
one best dress toaster she wasn't my
number one Oh who's your number one well
you I thought we were gonna start from
the bottom oh okay we could start from
the bottom okay my number three best
dress this was the hardest one I had I'm
gonna say Ana de Armas from knives out
wearing Ralph Emery so stunning I just
saw knives out it is so good she is so
beautiful and just to see her on the
carpet like being the snatcher for her
first Golden Globes I love to see it
stunning
I completely agree okay number two
number two you know it was kind of a
daring choice Joey King interesting I
thought it was beautiful it was
different she could have just shown up
in like a Zac Posen dress like everyone
else but it was really interesting I
think that she like had a lot to prove
because she was the youngest person
there for the most part who was
nominated and I just thought she looked
excellent it wasn't it wasn't the most
conventionally beautiful but I thought
it was the most daring yeah no and I
think the youngest person there was that
Jojo right yeah but I just mean like
she's like young Hollywood it was a
really big deal for her to be a dominate
it and even though she didn't win like I
just thought she really showed up we
could have we could have not been
speaking about her lecture right she
took a chance she didn't win she was not
the most famous person there but I
thought she it was a good choice okay
cool my number two and it could be
number one but I had number one for
someone else who just blew me away my
number two is Gwyneth Paltrow
Oh fabulous I endorse so cool
so Gweneth so timely and so timeless
that the overall consensus from people
on the internet which I know is not an
indication was people hated her dress
behind people hate her I was shocked and
maybe I only loved the dress because I'm
head over heels in love with Gwyneth
Paltrow but she looked amazing I thought
it was it was hot sure but also like
accessible I usually would like cheeks
on the e-news I thought it was kind of
sexy and conservative it was just
it was everything it was the oxymoron
dress I loved it it was perfect it was
perfect I agree I love that and she
looks beautiful sheet like just had this
glow about her she even like embodied
her character from the politician I just
thought it was yes she just knocked it
out of the park I'm really curious for
your best trustees because mine is Park
best-dressed because she looked
beautiful but also because I just like
standing her now Scarlett Johansson
oh she was maybe gonna be my number
three but I just like wanted to switch
it up a little bit yeah I completely
agree she looked incredible and I don't
know if she just like looked incredible
or I was like the sight of her and
colleges together which like made the
dress more beautiful either way number
one best dressed ya know and her face
she just like what she was radiating
there was a lot of radiation in the room
and she's not on my best-dressed list
but nicole kidman oh it's just every bit
the a-lister it was crazy because she
actually looked so much like Cameron
Wescott because Cameron wore a red gown
to the reunion which we will recap the
reunions this week as the new episodes
come out yes but it was just freaky to
see her there you know I wasn't Cameron
what are you doing they're supposed to
be in Cabo she just looked so beautiful
my number one best dress and they think
this is gonna shock people I just like
felt some type of way about and I just
wish I wanted to see so many other
people in that dress can I guess
actually no Renee Zellweger
oh that dress I loved her shoes oh my
god her toned arms like I'm not I don't
even stand like I know no clue and I
would have never even seen her dress if
she didn't win the award right and I was
just blown away I love the simplicity of
it I love to the color I loved it so
easy to forget about her because she
whispers and I totally forgot that she
was there but great call I would have
never known that she was there if she
didn't win she looked amazing and she
looked at me she was actually lovely and
sincere and I feel like she kind of
feels like an outsider because she used
to be like the belle of the ball and
then she like took 20 years off after
really getting married to Kenny Chesney
on a big [ __ ] yeah are they still marry
no they were married for like one minute
and they got like married on the beach
and there was you People magazine it was
like they're basically inspired right
Nicole Kidman she was obviously going
through something oh also the red carpet
was so great he was doing a really good
job of like bringing people together so
Laura Dern Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban
all that interviewed together and then
weirdly Paul Rudd came in because they
were all just and I like when
celebrities hang out so I really enjoyed
that Paul Rudd was being so funny Nicole
Kidman's had the most lovely genuine
things about Laura Dern I feel like
everyone in Hollywood kind of champions
Laura Dern and I never realized I know
she's been around for a while
I don't think I realized how long she'd
been on until they did that package of
Ellen's accomplishments and the episode
where she comes out and like you know
breaks the internet was she was talking
to Laura dirt uh-huh and I had no idea
cuz I've obviously never seen that show
or that episode it was like damn boy
turn and then she won and I felt like it
was such a good night for Laura Dern I
thought
did you see the marriage story no not
you to miss anything but her character
was amazing and I really thought she
deserved to win so I was so happy I
might watch it the show's didn't make me
want to watch some things mostly 19:17
because it won Best Picture and because
the guy speech was so cute it's like
it's hard to get recognition when you
don't have a movie star in your movie
our movie comes out next week like
please go see it and it's like what
better advertisement than winning Best
Picture
I just want to support that guy what
that's like something I mean honestly
one more one not the most entertaining
Wars yeah but like World War two was so
sad
no but like I think World War well I
mean World Wars was so sad it's personal
for at least world war two that if
there's like a wizard juice and stuff
and also like good triumphs over evil
inglorious basterds you know you can
make it that entertaining also one or
one is just oppressed I know this is
gonna sound crazy but like yeah the same
characters and so a lot of the bad blood
spilled over into World War two it
wasn't fully sussed out god I got it not
as crazy as World War Z that Brad Pitt
movie I had one more thing I wanted to
talk about but I can't oh someone else
who I thought looks incredible and I
just wanted to mention in my on the show
because I think it will get back to her
because she listens to the show and it
was my favorite look of hers of all time
someone who listens to this show yes who
participated in last night's events not
so far-fetched who Tanya rad oh my god
the snatchler oh my god I loved her
dress
I love she didn't change for InStyle
because that dress deserved to be
photographed on the red car oh my god
and I think it was Giovanni because
she's got robot oh my god she looked so
beautiful in her I loved the glam I
loved the dress and I just like I needed
more of it I agree and I thought she did
a great job II um it's weird because for
certain award shows II really gets their
[ __ ] together I feel like they have
Justin and Tanya and Hunter and Aaron
lamb like really being on the carpet and
they only had hunter and Aaron lit on
the carpet for like one minute and they
do the stupid AT&T commercial it was so
so mean and yeah I really wish they use
more of their talent more
they did like a Justin and Tonya did
like a Twitter thing which is great but
like I really want to see the money yeah
and Wells and honestly like not to be
mean and I I'm going to try my hardest
not to be mean but like it's time for
giuliana rancic to go yeah
like first of all she is so bad at her
job like she can't remember things about
people she asked everyone the same
question and Ryan Seacrest is great at
his job but he's like sitting there
talking to Charlie Theron about you know
you know the feminist movement I'm
starting from the riot roger ailes thing
and it's like let's do not forget you
know Ryan Seacrest was me - Daz well and
we just like kind of glaze over that so
it's like a little tone deaf I just
think it's really time even Jason
Kennedy like it's time for new people oh
I'd like Jason Kennedy there at a
certain point it's like Ryan Seacrest is
actually great for the job because he's
really friends with all these people
they give him that respect I don't know
if it had been anyone else if Brad Pitt
would have stopped by you know that's
true that's true he's a true
professional
yeah but Juliana man is just out of
control
yeah I saw her interview with Kirsten
Dunst and III really she called her
Jennifer Aniston did you see Ryan I
really felt like she didn't know who she
was talking to and it's like how dare
you two have no choice but to respect
her and Shipman like sit down I'm sexy
I'm cute and I'm also popular to boot
yeah I'm also [ __ ] in with great hair
but we'll talk about that later I
returned a few notes of things I wanted
to mention oh please do
Taylor Swift was there sure her and Joe
walked separately which is just so weird
like okay I get that if he's not gonna
come with her to stop she's not gonna
come with him but you're both in the
same room yeah
they set night to each other so we got
like one or two pictures of that and now
those were like the first posing
pictures you go out of them I was I saw
them on make the corner of the screen I
was so excited for you me too
I was sad that she lost but if she's
gonna lose tail to John to me that
doesn't feel like a loss like Elton John
is good but I actually I don't think she
could have won because of the reviews
that cats have been so awful but that
song um I know but that cats can't be a
golden globe-winning movie I just can't
be I have one complaint about the Golden
Globes
well I think that Beyonce was snubbed
and I think a lot I think Lion King as
Best Animated Film like oh my god what a
snub agreed and spirits should have won
Best Song agreed I thought that whatever
movie won it was like there was five
movies nominated for animated and for
them were huge names a whole could've
won
I'm frozen too and then there's no name
thing happened and I was like excuse me
what's this I guess it must have been
really good me and I yeah maybe
okay so teletrac was there and she gave
a present she presented an award mm-hmm
and she presented it with Amy Poehler
right and I remember having vague like
flashbacks to something happening at the
Golden Globes with Amy Poehler and then
I remembered that we always say there's
a special place in hell for women who
don't support other women and that's
actually we're joking but there's a
quote that Taylor Swift made about Tina
Fey and Amy Poehler when they was in the
Golden Globes years ago they made the
joke that like she did it so many guys
like it like their Golden Globes boys
they were like keep him away from Taylor
Swift some write Beckham do they send
Michael J Fox son yeah yeah and then she
said there's a special place in hell for
women who don't support other women and
then she was out there presenting with
Amy Poehler I don't know it's been years
but there's no continuity I needed to
know like what happened there yeah I'm
sure they kissed and made up but that
was a really severe statement for like a
joke ya know and it's like in the words
of Ricky Gervais is like they're just
jokes they're just jokes I agree
next thing I wanted to say I just would
like a wellness check on Jennifer
Aniston she was really not well um not
only on the red carpet I thought there
was something a little weird with her
but like maybe she's just excited then
when she presented the award she like
was having trouble reading off a
teleprompter she said there was gonna be
the video and then there was no video
and she was just being weird she was
giving me weird vibes oh I didn't I
didn't pick up on any of juniors vibes I
mean maybe she was startled by the fact
that her OTP was in the room and they're
both single right now and they were
spotted at the same intrument
after-party and maybe they're gonna get
back together in vanilla I couldn't if I
were her I could never after the public
shaming but as a fan like please they
also cut to her while Brad was speaking
and she was like making goo-goo eyes at
him I don't stand them at all like I
think one like she would be so silly to
go back to him just because of not even
what he did to her but like what the
media did like it was just too much and
also I just think honestly I think you
do better I agree but I just like I just
think it would be such a cute poetic
ending and they really are both
America's Sweethearts and if he can't be
with going to Paltrow like he should be
with her you should be with my pouch oh
I agree
after watching I mean after reading
Howard Stern's book even though I
believe in Brad Falchuk Gwyneth
Paltrow's love I'm not discounting that
I just think like what Brad Pitt did
took for granted Paltrow like at such a
pivotal time in his career was
astonishing
know like they're just
what maybe one day you never know and
then I want to talk about one of the
most one of the most talked about
moments which was giuliana rancic swag
was it awake horse Oh cuz it was like
blonder than she normally and it was
like so much hair she is like a bob now
I think it was the weirdest thing ever
like it was just first of all was such a
bad wig like it was Party City vibes
like it was really Halloween and then
she wear this like terrible dress it was
just she actually always kind of slays
it like she's great glam and she doesn't
wear like you know a Valentino dress but
she always finds like a unique designer
and it's like always like very like
elevated prom uh-huh I just thought she
looked horrible yeah it wasn't my
favorite look I didn't think the glam
was there speaking of looking horrible
will you have to talk about JLo I can't
agree with you it wasn't my favorite
look of hers by any means but I liked it
I do love her hair um terrible but I I
kind of like the dress she she likes
those big avant-garde dresses and it
wasn't my worst of the night my enemy it
was definitely down there for me I was
going through Twitter of old Golden
Globes that she was at just like being a
presenter and like she's literally
best-dressed at award shows that she
could very well doesn't need to be at
and I think this is your night you
almost won like it was just a big night
for you and like this is your best look
I was looking her her Justin last year
was amazing her hair was amazing like I
was just so let down this was terrible
it but it wasn't a letdown if anything
was to much you know like it wasn't no
it was a letdown I think what was a
letdown like when I saw it it didn't
really bother me until I started like
looking and I was like you know that's
kind of like big and stupid um but I
didn't it wasn't my worst she did
something different at least no because
I feel like she can she could really
easily be like a one-trick pony because
she is so snatched and she could always
just like a tight silver dress right
wear the green Versace dress everywhere
she goes
um but she did something different I
respected it okay another thing I want
to talk about was Ellen getting her
award because two things happen that
really shook me one to Kate McKinnon
come out as gay because I just never
knew that she was gay I don't think she
came out cuz it didn't wasn't framed
that way but um I didn't know either I
don't know either and like love love
that for her love the moment I'm I just
didn't know I wasn't wondering if that
was like news breaking or it was like
everyone knew that except for me perhaps
I think and then I want to
Ellen because her package had really
made me emotional and her speech was
hysterical hysterical what a night
honestly I take back everything I said
unless she had someone write it for her
because I was saying I really thought
her special was terrible like I was
saying like when you when you're on TV
for so long and people are writing for
you like maybe you just lose you're
funny and I thought maybe Ellen had lost
her funny but her speech was spectacular
and it almost made me forget it was so
funny it was so funny and it really did
a good job of making me forget because
it seems so genuine and then you
remember that she's the devil allegedly
and I've been thinking a lot about Ellen
being the devil allegedly because it's
like it's so crazy that she's either
like an angel amongst us or the devil
like the two and I actually asked a lot
of people recently like who work in
industry and who have worked a Jason to
her or even with her if the rumors are
true and like every single one it has
confirmed that they're true which is so
disappointing but I don't want it to
take away from the importance of Ellen's
career because she really is so
important and I think that she really
changed the landscape of TV and they
don't want to take away from her
accomplishments because I think that's
[ __ ] up and last night really proved
that she is like such an important
figure for LGBTQ people and for like
just the industry in general but I just
don't think we should forget that she's
the devil I I don't disagree that like
she probably is hard to work with like I
haven't heard all the same things that
you've heard but I've heard a few things
but I think like she she could be a bit
of both just like anyone you know maybe
she does have to be a hundred percent
devil maybe it's like 50/50 that's true
you know it happens on the day yeah it
does but I just think we shouldn't
forget that's all I'm saying
okay lest we not we won't forget and
then the last thing I wanted to talk
about was Aquafina so happy for her so
happy for digital creators everywhere
that's what I'm saying I was like
jumping for joy when she won him Ben was
like why she said he's like have you
seen this movie I'm like no but I'm like
this is a great moment for influencers
like and I oh I think about what
awkwafina's life could have been like
like after a girl code like she could
have just been like another funny like
influencer like making good money but
like she really is such a talent mm-hm
and I think her talent got her to the
place like look at all the other girl
code girls no one's at the Oscars no
one's at the Golden Globes like she is
really something else yeah I'm really
excited this feels like just the
beginning for her and I she just seemed
so genuinely surprised
grateful and it was really nice to see
because there were so many a listers
there so many people who have been
nominated so many times and I'm sure it
becomes a little month
so to see someone fresh on the scene
very exciting just like that guy from
succession who was like I've been in
this industry for 60 years and it's like
good for you I was so happy for him yeah
it's like everyone in the middle we get
it but like on the beginning or at the
end very exciting just like that guy
with the eyebrows I loved his speech
meet you in bed was like where do I know
I'm from where do I know I'm from I'm
like then you don't know him like just
face it
ya know did he watch Chernobyl I'm so
happy turn Obul got the respect that it
deserves right I don't know Chernobyl I
would just want one time to watch every
single thing that's nominated just so I
could know for sure if the right things
are winning you know ya know I've seen a
few I need to see knives out and I need
to see 1917 yeah those are those are my
two takeaways I might watch marriage
story just cuz it's on Netflix it's so
easy yeah I don't
so we'll see once again award shows
season has is coming going and no one's
wearing a bra like how is that possible
yeah I always think like how I can never
be famous cuz Saoirse Ronan showing up
and like a chainmail dress with no bra
like where is your third love girl no I
I have no clue I would be showing up
like tits up in a third love bra with my
back being fully supported and no wires
digging into my arm a dress my third
love third love oh yes who are you
wearing third love their love Dubrow
third love does bras differently they
believe that every woman deserves to
feel comfortable and confident everyday
with the right kind of support they help
her do that their bras are designed to
fit you and not the other way around
they're designed with measurements from
millions of women their bra styles are
made to fit your life
they've over 80 bra sizes but know that
there's only one that matters to you
there is so much it goes into finding a
good bra but 90% of it is knowing your
size and it took me 25 years other 10%
is going to third love me 25 years to
find the right bra size and I found it
by taking their fifth finder quiz you
basically answer a few simple questions
find your perfect fit in 60 seconds they
have over 15 million women who have
taken the quiz it's super fun
takes less than a minute to complete on
they have a perfect fit promise so every
customer has 60 days to wear the bra
wash it and put it to the test if you
don't love it the best part is that if
you can return it to third blob they
will wash it and donate it to a woman in
need so you don't have to feel bad about
not loving your bra even though I can
assure you that you will every customer
has just been super happy including
myself I have many different types of
their bras strapless but I think the
t-shirt bra is my favorite I'm wearing
it today
it's hands-down the most comfortable bra
you'll ever own they have straps that
don't slip and tagless labels so there's
no it
and they give back which is the best
part third live knows that there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they are offering our listeners 15% off
your first order go to third love calm
slash morning toast now to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 15% off your
first purchase
again that's third love.com slash
morning toast for 15% off today check it
out get your titties and in the words of
Nilsa from Laura Bama short chichis up
sign on get your tits up okay it was
only one story I know it's really crazy
next story is such exciting beautiful
news Cameron Diaz and Benji Madden
daughter radix was born right before New
Year's says Cameron herself today posted
something on Instagram just like a brief
little statement letting everyone know
that the baby is here they did you like
a big pregnancy announcement I think
that this is so amazing and it it
encouraged me to go down like a rabbit
hole of like the Madden brothers Good
Charlotte they're on tour like I was
just like looking into them because I
kind of forgot about them um and I used
to tell everyone and I thought 100% that
their mom was Steve Madden and that's
not true dad whatever that's not true no
it's not true we've already told people
that do you think Cameron Diaz and
Nicole Richie hang out because their
brothers are their husbands our brothers
like unfortunately I don't think so
otherwise they would be best friends so
they were either best friends or not
friends but I think they actually might
hang out together but Cameron Diaz is
very private like she doesn't really
post on Instagram she doesn't work
anymore she's pretty much like retired
actress because she made 80 million
dollars in tracks so like good for you
um so they might hang out but just like
not take pictures you know yeah I
wouldn't know
there is no way to know but I'm just so
happy for her and I and I feel like
she's coming back soon I just feel it in
my soul um because she's been doing some
more public stuff she like did an
interview recently and I just I think
the world needs more Cameron Diaz I
think we're suffering without her and it
and it took me so long in my life for me
to appreciate her Joe and I just I'm so
mad at myself for not appreciating her
when we had her there was a time when
she was like in every rom-com and to me
she was just like a Katherine Heigl
nothing special
I'd like a Kate Hudson who I also didn't
appreciate for far too long right but
then like in the other woman and that's
when I really appreciated Cameron Diaz
for like the true town that she was and
then I I realized like her catalog of
work is so impressive it's so impressive
you have to watch mad teacher like you
will fall in love with her even more I
do I do if I was a teacher and I was
ever like feeling down about the work
that I was doing I would just watch bad
teacher okay because every time I watch
it it makes me want to
teacher and I've never had that that
urge I also think that she had a very
hard time getting pregnant because this
is her first child and I'm just like so
happy that she like she's on the other
side of it now like she has a child and
I was putting on my Instagram story like
how happy I was for her and I got like a
few messages like but the baby's name
shut the [ __ ] up okay
who cares not your baby when I need my
check radix no what do I give a [ __ ] no
I don't mind it call it rad it's just
hard to say radix Maddon Radek there
really to say like that yeah it's Maddon
radix Maddon the little tongue twister
not really only when you twist kind of
mad and only when you twist your tongue
it's a little challenging okay you ready
for our next story
sure cuz the kotel lineup has come out
and I just find it always to be an
interesting bit of news because it's
really a sign of the times it's a sign
of the times and I think at first when I
saw the three headliners I was like very
mad about it
but if you look towards like line two
and three I think it actually it's not
terrible like I think this is the most
excited I've ever been for a Coachella
end up knowing that this lineup was not
made for me whatsoever right and we have
very specific taste so the three
headliners are Rage Against the Machine
Travis Scott stormy Chad and Frank Ocean
like okay cool and then some of the
standout acts are Calvin Harris run the
jewels
meg B stallion Brock Hampton Big Sean
flume disclosure 21 savage Danny Elfman
I'm really excited about that as if I
think I'm going so he's like that he
does music scores remember how we almost
went to Hans Zimmer but there were too
many people so basically every movie
that Hans Zimmer hasn't done Danny
Elfman has done oh I like that yeah I
like that too and if we do you go to a
cello we should go to Danny Elfman I
think the most underrated person on this
list who's like named really just like
faded into the background was Calvin
Harris which is so underrated like he's
an amazing DJ yeah I think that would be
so fun that was like when we saw a
diplomate stagecoach like a rave it's so
much fun so much fun also Lana Del Rey
little Uzi vert fka twigs lil nas some
of the ones that I'm most excited about
which are like in the smallest of Prince
Louis Capaldi [ __ ] love him agreed
lost Kings lost Kings Kim Petrus love
will be so good and then also born
Daigle love
like that's oh and also the Martinez
brothers are back and I knew or you
would want to know that holy [ __ ] I knew
you would want to know that I don't know
what the Martinez brothers looks like
I've never heard any of their something
you're their number one fan but I'm
their number one fan for what they stand
for
yeah Coachella and family that's so
crazy I don't know if we are gonna go
but we're definitely gonna stagecoach
this year I feel like we'll line up at
Coachella which is why I was interested
in yeah I know we always say we're not
gonna go but at the end of the day the
show is supposed to be the epicenter of
all things cool and culture and sorry
that's what Ellis Ellis Coachella yeah
but what I am excited about I don't
listen to Travis Scott's music but I'm
excited for what's gonna be um Coachella
because he's just gonna come with like
with Kylie maybe stormy and look at like
house and then like all that Kardashian
adjacent and I just think like we might
run into Kylie like maybe it could
happen we could like walk past her yeah
well she could probably walk past us
or maybe like stormy will be there like
in a flower crown they be so cute that
would be so cute anyways I just I
thought it was an interesting factoid
and then once I just said it was a sign
of the times it makes me realize Harry
Styles would be great for Coachella yeah
maybe not a headliner maybe I like the
second to last that's a great call he's
very Coachella aesthetic with his
bell-bottom pants totally so I'm gonna
take a picture of th yeah because he's
being so Cu T right now yeah he's being
extra Cu T he's just sleeping on the
equipment oh my god cute just like
making sure everything's going well I'm
better that's a great call about Harry
Styles I like that a lot
honestly Niall Horan - I'm like such a
Sam Niall Horan is just doing incredible
things these incredible things for music
for women like for everything so I
didn't listen to the song but you see
that Harry Hailee Steinfeld really is a
song called wrong direction I listened
to it once I was doing my hair and it
just didn't stand out to me but Margot
said it's about Niall Horan like One
Direction wrong direction
interests and I put a cryptic um like
teaser for her new album that's like
allegedly coming out this month on her
Instagram and the caption was you could
have bought a different ring for her so
now people are like did he propose but
no no maybe someone who was gonna
propose to Julia Michaels used but it's
like first of all I don't think that
Justin Bieber proposed to Selena Gomez
and if he did like people talked about
it like it's so pertinent
they haven't dated in like five years no
I was actually just reflecting on
mr. and mrs. Bieber and how like when we
first reported that they were engaged
they were thrown in with a with like
Pete and Ariana and Nick and Priyanka oh
and by the way she was almost my third
best-dressed I thought she looked
incredible a she looked so good but the
night was literally ruined when he
called her baby on stage ya know it was
just like too much but I she was gonna
be my third best dress but then I had to
give it to Ana she was actually the
definition of the snatch I liked her
waist and jewels and the lipstick and
the hair it was perfection um anyway so
I feel like for a while no one really
respected Justin and Haley Bieber and so
not only did they get married so quickly
after they got engaged like in a
courthouse but then they did the whole
wedding shebang and like they really are
doing the damn thing in the words of
Becca Cooper they're proving everyone
wrong yeah and I just have a lot of
respect for their relationship it must
be so hard so hard everyone is always
talking about Selena Gomez when they
literally am and you know what she fans
the flames with her music like releasing
songs that you probably wrote she
definitely not right but like that were
about how she felt about him like ten
years ago like she really needs to stop
yeah because all of the fans like always
come for healing and Selena really could
be doing something to stop because
honestly they need like she dated the
weekend like there's pretty much and I
still ship those to meet you and is he
still with Bella his life confuses me
yeah I don't know I feel like him and
Mellor endgame but then I'm like but
when he was with Selena they both seemed
so happy you know I actually think him
in Bella our end game and I don't know
who like Selena's OTP is but it's not
Justin Bieber and they need to stop and
respect the sanctity of marriage and I'm
like Justin Bieber but we need to talk
about yummy cuz it's just not what I
needed maybe lose you to love me is
about that weekend
yeah we're just like maybe someone she
dated quietly like a high school
sweetheart right Jonas said I didn't
know Charles Milton and Camilla Mendes
broke up I know I heard I tried not to
think about it too much because it was
upsetting um but it just never really
worked for me because of the way things
panned out on Riverdale I'm like var Chi
for me is OTP like I'm obsessed with
them and so to know that in real life
she's dating Reggie it just doesn't work
no but I did like them together but they
very quietly broke up for like I was
kind of like public they were you know
yeah as public as they were that wasn't
it
I just want happiness for both of them
but that's a great segue into our next
story because another river oil star
has found eternal love Vanessa Morgan
has married White Sox pitcher Michael
kopeck also known as Brio biermann's
ex-boyfriend like normally this really
wouldn't be a story and I don't think
anyone would care but the Brio Biermann
of it all is very interesting and quite
shocking this is fascinating stuff
fascinating because the last we saw a
Michael Kovak on don't be tardy was then
we're gonna be ready to move in together
and then they really abruptly broke up
and he very quickly started dating
Vanessa Morgan and I didn't even know
that they had gotten engaged but that
was like obviously just and they weren't
hiding it like she's been posting about
her bachelorette party should put
sneakers bride-to-be on her Instagram
story like they were very much getting
married we haven't seen any pictures yet
but like they weren't hiding this I just
felt like it was a big secret oh I
didn't feel like this big secret I just
don't think you follow either of them so
why would you know anything but I just
like know so much about Michael Kovak
because of Brielle Biermann also we have
a lot to talk about with Brielle Berman
as well she's getting her lips dissolved
yeah which is crazy
I saw I think it's great I'm excited for
her I'm excited whatever makes you happy
girl yeah no I think she looks beautiful
no matter what nataline catch was at the
wedding with her boyfriend Travis yeah I
believe Camila Mendes was there as well
yeah Camila Mendes was on The
Bachelorette which Madeline was not but
I always thought that Madeline and
Vanessa we're the best of friends that's
because they're dating in the show no
but it's also like I just think they're
the best like how Lilian Cammie lived
together yeah I just think like Vanessa
and Madeline have really become tight
it's nice at all the river KITT
Riverdale kids like I think whenever
you're shot to start I'm on the TV show
like that like you all become best
friends obviously but like now it's like
they're not the number one show on
television but like they're very
successful they're more settled into
being what like and being they know what
it means to be a celebrity and they're
still so close like I think that's nice
I think it's nice too
they could have fizzled out yeah but
it's only season four season four it's
just been awhile since they shot to
start them and now it's all like a
regular for them yeah but they have like
18 million Instagram followers like life
is good yeah exciting that was like such
a good show for any of them to be on
because not only do you become like an
actress you get to go to like amazing
award shows but then after that like if
all else fails we have 18 million
Instagram followers and like that's a
life yeah I greet hanger bills I agree
for the final story
speaking of being an influencer who can
now pay her bills bachelor contestant
Jade Roberto Burt wins 1 million dollars
on daily fantasy football this was crazy
like it's a there's some draftkings
which is like you pay like five like
it's like a million
people dollar and then if you get it
right like you win the pot and they won
so crazy so crazy like now I want to get
involved no I know I'm like so happy for
her and I know she does well and but
this is just like blessings on blessings
I don't know Lessing's on but it's cool
that like someone who's like you see the
username of the person who won it's like
cool that's someone that a lot of people
know yeah I think that a lot of people
like I saw weights being like yeah like
why are you playing like because I guess
she has a lovely life but like she wants
to gamble in her free time let her oh
yeah Jade Roper Tolbert can do whatever
she wants anyway well so can Jade repair
tobei that's exactly what I was into
then they could take on the world
you're a dynamic duo I'm really happy
for her what she's gonna do with the
money after taxes yeah so like the $3
once she gets in I think that's so crazy
like you always hear about things like
that happen do you read about them in
the paper but it never happens to
someone you know and I don't know Jade
Roper Tolbert it never happens to
someone famous but i know of her yeah
and i always thought that like um
remember you know every like you maybe
once a year people get all excited
because the Powerball reaches like
something amazing like historic 300
million and everyone buys a ticket and
if it's like chrissy teigen bought a
ticket and she won she would obviously
like make it into like a philanthropic
moment because she's very self-aware
mm-hmm but if you like celebrities buy
lottery tickets too right yeah and like
I feel like if they won there would be
like mass outrage oh and yet they would
they would have to you're taking it away
from like someone who really [ __ ]
wants it and needs it but I think the
amount of celebrities that buy lotto
tickets is probably not that much and
like it's probably less than point zero
zero zero five percent of the whole odds
of winning the lottery or so slim and
then the odds of it being a celebrity or
like even more slim I'm just saying like
I would hope I live in a time where a
celebrity wins a lottery and like I
would love to know what people say about
it okay that was a interesting because I
thought that a lot I think you know what
people will say yeah and I thought a lot
of people would be like on Jade Roberto
bird about it like saying and that she
took it away from my god but she did
what she wants she was I don't yeah it's
about like picking teams I'm assuming
think yeah but anyways that's so
exciting for her I hope they I feel like
they're always like taking fabulous
trips cuz they're influencer so I don't
know she has like two kids she yeah I'm
fine with that
yeah I'm excited about it mad that I
didn't get in it's cute that like you
know boyfriends and girlfriends around
the world they can come together
because like they're at work in The
Bachelor have come together totally look
at you getting introduced traditional
gender stereotypes my god Jackie totally
also I hope the snatcher covers this
base story yeah it's big news I can't
wait to hear what Ches to say so
it's officially 2020 it's winter I'm
like what um where are you shopping like
I need a whole new wardrobe like I feel
like I watch old episodes of the Choson
like in every thumbnail I'm wearing the
same three sweaters like you know and
the same one pair of boots I just got
new boots actually I'm from new company
of heard of Rafi's yes I think they're
so good thing they're sponsor of the
show I got these sneakers from them that
are like so comfortable and I don't know
if you guys know this but I have flat
feet so it's it's very important what I
choose to put up see this well what I
choose to put on my feet and the
sneakers are like slip-on they're tan
they're just like premium and you could
put them in the laundry machine which is
so important because somehow I'm like
always playing in the mud apparently you
know when I walk Theo like literally all
my shoes I've done like one of those
nerds who leaves their shoes outside
their door you know but I never even
thought of having shoes that are machine
washable but that's the whole basis
around the companies um Rafi's and I
think it's really lucky genius agreed
Alice more have you heard about this
company making stylish shoes for women
and girls out of recycled plastic water
bottles oh and they're crazy comfortable
and fully machine washable Ravi's has
quickly gone to a moat quickly grown to
a most-loved gotta have them brand it's
no surprise they have over a thousand
nearly perfect reviews they're stylish
sustainable comfortable washable ready
really all in one pairs of shoes they're
the perfect flats for life on the go so
they're the perfect everyday shoes for
life on the go they're stylish and
comfortable they come an ever-changing
array of colors prints patterns and
they're available in in a range of
styles like sneakers loafers points and
more they launch new colors and patterns
every few weeks and they sell out
constantly playfully design add playful
designs add fun pops of color they perk
up every outfit while still looking
polished and professional they are
seamlessly knit using thread made from
plastic water bottles so they're
completely ultra comfortable and as soon
as you slip them on there's zero
break-in period there's zero break-in
period I hate wearing shoes that like
make you bleed for a few days and then
you're like I love that yeah and then
you're like crying inside like that
episode from friends where Monica buys
these expensive boots I won't go into
bed um it'll blow your mind that they're
made from repurposed plastic water
bottles in fact they've diverted over 35
million water bottles from landfills
already we love a company with a mission
with
statement and we fully support a
sustainable brand go to Roth ease ro t
hy s comm / toast to get your new
favorite flats check out all the amazing
styles available right now at Roth is
calm slash toasts head to Roth is calm
slash toes today their comfortable
stylish and sustainable their the shoes
you've been waiting for you can throw
them in the wash it's pretty genius Roth
is calm slash toast check it out
new brand that we think you guys will
really enjoy because we know you're some
sustainable Queens
ya know love them they're so sleek and
chic and like cozy and great for a
grandma like me so totally now that we
are 2020 season 3 of the morning shows
mm I think we should set some goals okay
just like ethically you know physical
goals are always good tangible goals
mm-hmm um I'm excited for her set to
like really get checked out every day we
sit here one thing will be change will
have a new camera woman ooh yeah a new
table so we're just really excited to
like evolve the Sun did come out I just
want to give credit to where credit to
the Sun to mother nature she's a she's a
true queen and it looks kind of kind of
beautiful yeah a lot of I'm reading the
comments now on YouTube a lot of people
are asking if this is a green screen no
it's not it is real New York you'll see
the Sun come out and to see a plane
maybe we could see Sully oh my gosh that
was another thing from Tom Hanks's
glazed over selling almost forgot no I
was waiting the whole time I was like
where's Sully soley soley soley like
it's all about Sully and I just felt
like they didn't do Chesley Sullenberger
justice nor Tom Hanks it was really just
like a two second clip of Sully like it
was so much more than that so much more
exceeds lives crazy both human and dog
crazy
okay so goals I mean I think we all be
about the same goal like from last year
in terms of gasses like we need a
kardashian-jenner on the toast right and
we have some other people now on the
list we need jeffree star I've added Guy
Fieri to the list Howard Stern Howard
Stern or just like maybe what's going on
Howard Stern works too or just like
sitting in like the bathroom in his
studio and like waiting for him to come
in you know that works that works
whatever take it outside the serious
office it's on six Avenue
whatever it is let me know inserted ooh
perfect by the way I watched Chisholm
New Year's Eve special did you yeah
because we got home from New Year's and
we wanted to we turn on like the ball
dropping thing it was over but
la was still happening so he just wound
up watching everything like over again
and then we saw Andy and Anderson and it
was like so crazy you know but they get
crazy they get so drunk they like talk
about dick ancien and it's crazy people
love it like Anderson is III familiar
with him like he's the heavy like he's
like a real newscaster like he couldn't
read he couldn't speak
they were taken child it was so crazy
they were video chatting people in the
video chatted in Keith and Nicole Kidman
and the stream was like so janky was
like everyone was talking over each
other it was such a waster and then they
literally videoconference in Lindsay
Lohan from Oman what and her connection
was better than any people down the
street it was so crazy and then they
like took a shot of Jagermeister
Anderson was being funny about that it
was really reminding me of me and you
like I guess I'm the Anderson and they
have a great rapport because they're so
different yeah and that's why people
love them that's why they go on tour
together and that's why they're perfect
for something like that because Andy's
so turn up I think my absolute favorite
thing was I think maybe a year or two
ago it was raining and Andy you're
sitting outside and Andy and Anderson
had umbrellas and then like the
television union yelled at them saying
you're not allowed to have umbrellas and
the whole time they were on the stream
complaining that the people from
Univision had umbrellas and he's been
commenting on people's and instagrams
like from people you keep doing
throwback like what an amazing time at a
New Year's Eve with an umbrella he's
like I literally can't get over the fact
that they made me put my umbrella down
that's so funny I really felt like it
was weird cuz it was on CNN but it felt
like what it would be like if you and I
did a New Year's rice ball drop and that
was also what I was thinking with the
Golden Globes like if we'd been there no
one would have spoken to us so like it
was pointless but like if you and I like
we're hosting a like we're so funny I
had so many important questions for
people like torn Chipman like I don't
really need to hear about what it's like
to be a god in Florida like I just want
to hear more about like how do you feel
bring it on really catapulted into your
career and like what does it feel like
to be married to in lunge landry from
front nightlights right and like how do
you feel about the fact that there was a
murder in season two a DB watch the
whole show do you hang out with Coach
Taylor
but when coach tiller was there did he
say hi to Landry it's just there's so
much of that and it's it's so crazy and
you know there were a few team of
Thrones people in the room but usually
usually they all come together but there
was no Game of Thrones tables like
nobody's nominated except for cook kit
and Russ Leslie were together but then
Tommen is in 1917 the Pope guy was the
the one of the popes
one of the Pope's is the guy the cept in
Game of Thrones yes you know him know
you know the cept I forgive a military
the military priest guy I'm sure I know
but no Claudia came through people in
rooms like war are literally he's so who
subject circita shame oh my god he's one
of the Pope's he's a devil he's a devil
there were so many like random gain of
Game of Thrones people and I was just
wondering like if they if they synced up
totally it was interesting I like donut
in this dream because the Sun finally
came out in her sin looks so fun oh my
god it's so beautiful I mean there's a
million other things that we could talk
about like what else what else do you
watch fans you know oh right our plans
for 2020 very sadly I do believe we were
going to retire these chairs they have
been so good to us we're not gonna get
rid of them we're gonna keep them in our
office but I I'm so over this chair and
the sound it makes when I move like I
feel so fat like I'm a [ __ ] like a
freight truck like moving busy sorry but
I think sometimes on the audio it sounds
like a fart because I once heard a clip
where it straight up sounded like
someone farted but like we spoke about
it and I know it wasn't you and I know
it wasn't right I mean I bother actually
don't think I've ever farted on the show
which is so crazy maybe that's a good
goal 422 fart on the show I think it's
just the time of day like it's a little
early yeah I drink coffee yeah that's
actually I can legally I would be the
culprit I can't believe that like you
drink a full coffee before and during
the show and like you don't like have
diarrhea on the show well now at this
point like my body like we're a timed
machine you also know like you're a
queen and you don't have diarrhea so
diarrhea is basically like duty that
comes out of your mouth but it's like
really soft and fast and kind of hot
sometimes yeah it's cool I'm just very
excited like for this whole thing I
can't believe our stream work today like
it's just such a blessing and I want to
jinx it but I believe our audio is like
so premium I'm just really excited I'm
sure we will have technical difficulties
in the first few weeks so just bear with
us but today was really good I'm really
excited about it when I think back to
our first episode of the toast ever in
that Vayner studio like this is so much
better than that so I feel good right
but it's like it's also been a year and
a half like it it has to be better but
it was it felt like that first day
really I was so excited but so nervous
it was really like the first day of
school we have Real Housewives of New
Jersey this week Dallas OCS over do you
want to talk about OC really quick yeah
because I had a lot of life-changing
thoughts like what I went into the
reunion thinking and what I left was so
different I think Vicki is literally the
worst person on planet Earth
and not even in terms of the drama
because Kelly does stuff to her she does
up to Kelly like they're both wrong
they're both bad but it's just beyond
that it's a level of entitlement I think
what she said to broaden was so [ __ ]
rude and kind of homophobic and I was
really shocked that Andy didn't step in
and be like you saying two girls kissing
is homophobic like I just said she was
so um unabashed it's not the right word
like yeah she was just so didn't give a
[ __ ] I really really [ __ ] hate her
she was so mean - Bronwyn like really
judging her for her life choices and
like okay do I do that no do I judge
other people who like bring a woman into
their bedroom no all the power to you I
just thought she was so rude so
judgmental and really on a high horse
for someone who's not even a full time
cast mate yeah I think the way that she
was talking to everyone to the people on
the couch is like telling Bronwyn to get
off her show like Bronwyn it is more
brahmand show than it is your show and I
just and her telling Andy like you know
that she made the housewives what it is
it's like no one should have that level
of entitlement her saying she didn't
audition and then then rolling the tapes
it's just like it's not and that doesn't
make for a fair play yeah like a
Fairfield when they're filming the show
if one person feels like it's their show
and I actually feel like it's time to
clean house me too
also you can tell a lot about a person
when they don't realize they're on
camera and when she left and realized
that everyone else was gonna continue
filming and she was being let go early
and she was yelling at a producer in her
dressing room and she didn't know that
the camera was on her like that's that's
the real Vicki and that was insane you
cannot speak to people that way
but yeah they're they work with you not
for you even if they did work for you
you can't [ __ ] speak to people like
that and I understand why she feels
disrespected um but there's just a
different way of handling it yeah and
you know what like if you really feel
that so disrespected like don't then
don't be on the show at all great you
know make your point and leave agreed I
wouldn't want to say the MVP of the
third part of the reunion was weirdly
Shane and I put this on my Instagram
story and not a lot of people agree with
me but I just thought I definitely this
whole time thought he's been
misunderstood because nobody's that big
of a dick while on TV and no one's that
big of a dick while they're still gonna
stay married like if there were if this
season while the season was airing it
came out that Emily filed for divorce
and would have all make sense but the
fact that there doesn't seem like
divorces on the horizon at all makes it
feel like it's not so terminal yeah and
I got the vibe he's definitely a weird
guy and has a weird sense of humor and I
definitely don't get it but what I got
from him being on the
Union Wood said he's kind of weird and
shy and I actually felt like and he was
really hard on him and he and he took it
in stride and he was really fine and he
spoke very openly about their marriage
and he didn't make jokes when he was
talking about like the words they did
and he didn't make fun of it and yes I
think he was evil for doing the bread
thing but I do think he meant it as a
joke like I really do and Emily didn't
seem to be so upset and I like Emily so
much like I just I want to believe in
Shane because I believe in Emily I
believe in them I don't think the bread
thing was so crazy maybe I'm remembering
it was really mean
What did he say it was just like
taunting her with the bread when she was
trying to be good like it was really
[ __ ] me I don't think that that's so
mean it's me it's like I could see miss
I don't think that that's so mean I
don't know it is well I'm glad that he
got to speak for himself because I felt
the same way that there was had to be
something that we weren't seeing and
apparently like it's the complete
opposite right like he's that is who he
is he's unapologetically himself and
he's like a weird guy and I think that's
fine and you know what like maybe he
should take out a book out of Brian
Redmon's book and just not come on
anymore because it's not doing him any
service you know and like let him only
just be yourself yeah and be friends
with Jeana be friends with everyone she
I do think it's time to let Vicki go I
do think it might be time to let Tamra
go I don't think it's time yet for
Shannon you know what as this Shannon
beador apologists that I am I was really
disappointed in her at the Reunion yeah
like I think she picked all the wrong
side yeah I think that anytime someone
said something remotely fair towards her
she's just sort of like mimics them she
dismissed kelly dodd completely when
like oh hello Kelly Dodds oh my god had
so many valid points and it's this is
the first time that I actually I can't
defend Shannon at all that's crazy
hmm and I've defended her through
everything but like she is now in a
really good place and she's just not
seeing clearly and I just think she
everyone else really came like open to
reconciliation you know like it got
really messy but then they actually
ended off in a better place but like she
was just so closed off to everything and
and I don't love to see that for my
Housewives yeah and everyone got
emotional like even Vicki and and Kelly
if I can make up any one can make a
million Jeana reconciled like everyone
was open you're right and and Chanin was
just not she she's so right she was just
parroting like what other people were
saying and I just I was disappointed
yeah I feel that
as the resident Jeana kirshen hider
champion I was really proud of
her oh my god by the way I cannot I had
no I mean how are we to know that all of
that was happening I knew he had
arrested for domestic violence but I had
no idea what is its mission of domestic
violence so it could have he could have
been suspected it could've been a
misunderstanding right but like I had no
idea what that night actually entail
then when she was like getting so choked
up saying she was running to the
neighbor's house and he came back and
grabbed her like I literally started
crying it gave me such chills and I had
no idea that it was that bad and I'm so
happy they're not together anymore
so happy they're not together like so
brave of her to like share her story to
continue to share it and I feel as
though like when these things are so
unfortunate in that we have to hear
about them but it really helps you
understand a person more and I feel like
I'm really here for Gina Cristian Haider
like so crazy ya know and I think she
she's actually very logical especially
when she's speaking about other people's
haha she was like getting involved in
the Kelly um Vicky drama she wasn't
taking a side she was just being very
third-party and and like no and what she
said like really put it to bed on bing
bong Bing bong vain and it's just like
back and forth and then like who can be
who can insult someone worse and then be
the bigger victim and it's just a cycle
and and II agreed with her and then they
put it to bed like yeah Gina Gershon
hide her like ice maker of our
generation I don't always agree with her
in her own fights because she gets
emotional and sick about herself but I
think when it comes to other people
she's actually like a great moral
compass of the show for other people
yeah she's definitely grown on me since
he's in one I hope she comes back I
think like my tied for favorite is
literally like Emily and Kelly like I
love Ellen Emily's so much like I just
champion her and I want her to get out
of this like ugly space that she's in
because I think there's a side to her
that she hasn't shown yet where she's
fun Emily mm-hmm and she's hilarious and
she's still smart lawyer serious girl
but she's also really cool and fun so I
think that'll be there for us sometime
soon next season I'm very excited and I
hope that they big clean house yeah I
think that they will but I hope that
they don't get rid of Kelly like I feel
like it's just about to get good no no
they can't like she's engaged and she is
such an interesting life now she's gonna
be bicoastal mhm she's engaged with that
massive ring there's a lot to Kelly Dodd
I don't think she's going anywhere she
was very integral like to the season
okay and I just love her me too and
she's got to move out to that apartment
yeah even though it's toasted they got
into Walmart they did and Simpson
I mean ask believe receive yesterday
manifest destiny okay that is really all
we have for you guys we hope you enjoyed
our first show back season three
premiere we're very excited for this
year it's gonna be very toasty we are
just gonna continue to be delivering
premium content because that's what we
know you guys love we love you so much
thank you for listening to the morning
to us the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast pretty
much anywhere podcasts can be bounced
that's Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio in our videocast box all the
places so subscribe wherever you listen
to podcasts leave a five star view about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys so so so so much have
an amazing day Muta Morrow bright and
early 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time let's pray
that the Sun comes out okay bye